à la fin de leur journée ces deux agents
auront tôt les faits plus d'une tonne de
déchets des ordures ménagères des
encombrants déposés sur la voie publique
une situation devenue tour c'est un
problème je dirais exponentielle parce
que je vous parle de 23 tonnes
aujourd'hui par mois il ya quelques l'an
dernier on était à 20 tonnes et donc il
ya vraiment une nécessité
ses prestations de collecte de dépôts
sauvages reviennent à peu près à 150000
euros à l'année vous luttez contre ces
incivilités à répétition la commune a
décidé d'agir dès le mois de juin dix
caméras ont été installées au niveau de
ces points de collecte
depuis ce poste de surveillance les
policiers identifient toute personne
prise en flagrant délit d'abandon
d'ordures elles sont verbalisées
ces images effectivement donc peur
effectivement nous permettre
d'identifier les contrevenants également
en identifiant leurs véhicules et puis
de transmettre à l'officier du ministère
public et en même temps
dans le même envoi au procureur et donc
après le juge du tribunal de police donc
procédera à la contravention
d'autres caméras vont être installées
dans les prochains mois une mesure qui
séduit ses habitants je trouve ça très
bien bien sûr je pense que les gens qui
font des déchets sauvages doivent être
punis par la loi et puis voilà c'est
normal ça fait partie de la vie mais
bientôt tout le monde respecte lui des
wii est bonne mais faudrait qu'elle soit
sévèrement verbalisable est ce qu'ils
voulaient pas multiplier par deux ou par
trois la mode
pour le moment aucune personne n'a été
verbalisée avec ce dispositif encore en
phase de test
à terme la vente sera de 68 euros